together totally different my sister
yeah just huge boobs and like tall and
really big curly hair
I've only look at your eyes I am NOT
gonna many good comments about your
friend she looks like me but more Jewish
oh no no hey hey I'm Kathy Lehr man you
can follow her on Instagram a friend of
mine who introduced you to archery yes I
finally joined the archery I've been
like five times I mean five times
I'm gotten pretty good at it I know it
makes me really mad why I'm not been on
you know I may be little hey Cassidy was
telling me how recently she watched the
Justice League trailer I loved it so
there's this video that I gotten [ __ ]
kind of request for ice cream shot the
first request that came in because I was
like I know a lot of people are going to
request this Beyonce Wimbush says react
to Avengers react to the Justice League
trailer okay I'm really excited for this
all right be on tech your wish will be
granted
look at that way
just like me YouTube spy for you from
the measure the inner electron is are
watching the place they put their
justice my trailer right there you the
others
yeah whoever you're looking for it's not
me here and mommy no
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
[Laughter]
it shows the perfect reaction
shall we
it's good to see you playing well with
others again just like that I dig it
they may be temporary that's so cool
[Laughter]
well you're gonna show up again the risk
is far greater you can do nothing but we
need to make some calls
you think this is funny no it's probably
not right missus is careful I have real
equation our very strength invites
challenge challenge in kind of
comfortable swimming to make cities with
you dangers how are you guys planning
meeting us together
you will lose and what do you have to
get into
oh okay oh good couple here they got
like oh you know I got an ant man with
an anyway yeah that's my very good
slicing him like video Civil War for
this from a troll try they do giggity
make it look like they're all the same
room that was good doctor but Machop
Machop oh my cockle only Cole thousand
followers do this videos probably boom
anything congratulations on the video
that's awesome
oh my god but were the best man I've
ever seen the girl went on for one woman
in the maze last access code ransomware
yeah
alright talking about cyborg remembers
I'm rich and they come back with giant
shark yeah I'm good good line for
anything that like what's your
superpower I'm rich Justice League is
coming out for the DC movies and then
Avengers infinity war is coming out soon
he has so many little watch all of that
yeah there may be no no they're good you
always entertaining I never am never
bored at least even if they're not to
cook even if it's not a great one I'm
like and still entertain but this is
this is getting me excited for like oh
my god you get you make you make you
feel like they're actually going to
match up against each other that's I got
nothing I'm like they just drew the
trailer Justice League but I'm like huh
this could happen wonder how you do with
any real is the studios could work
together and make that happen one day
that would be the craziest superhero
phenomenon I think will ever witness I'm
so giddy I wish this was real
yeah right that's what the step of this
video it does it makes you wish this is
all real not just good like I I just
think that I want to see every superhero
fight each other all Dylan's all the
superheroes like every world come
together
oh yeah be so much food have you sold
your Flash oh my god I'm so excited as a
Miller I think you should throw in the
Kardashian in there too yeah and we can
all kill kill with her - yeah
Valek on you
write a song about it if you watching
the reactions on you yeah you never know
what that guy watches right never know
what shiny is okay I just think he's
fantastic
they should just make more you're typing
no that's fine your type I mean I don't
think anyone said you're not a real
human like not really I would go get out
of your tiny long hair buckets [ __ ] you
like I mean like you watch the Carhartt
ad which you're not see it was
devastating but it's so good and so
inspiring they're like they're perfect
they're the perfect marriage perfect
kids it's just perfect
everyone's excited for the Justice
League mashup yeah this is prepping me
for when Avengers and finding the third
one comes out which is just going to
like in terms of crossover and collabs
oh my god it's going to be banana
sandwich I'm so excited
anyone can we add that pool into the mix
all right guys
dr. Michiko macaque Oh doctor yeah do
whatever subscribe to him immediately
subscribe to the real reject thank you
and this how did I miss the camera man
it's like awesome boy what a thing that
you did Nicky animal was that Cassidy
you can go to her Instagram I follow her
there link in the description box
please follow her you look she means the
fall nah I think I'm good
don't I'm just kidding follow me to your
account private no that would be fine
abhi I mean us weird on the private
account right I don't know Mimi it's not
enough smart it depends on your
personality trail very private person I
think you are alright No
[Laughter]